next nato expansion a group opposed to
the inclusion of the baltic states into
nato held a briefing today
representatives from the american
defense institute the eagle forum and
the media research center took part in
this 40-minute briefing
good morning
and welcome to the first news conference
of the coalition against nato expansion
i'm bill lind from the free congress
foundation with me is john isaacs from
the council for a livable world
one of the rare phenomenon in washington
is to see the left and the right
agreeing on anything
and even more rare
is a situation where major organizations
on the left and on the right actually
work together
the coalition against nato expansion
is one of those most rare situations
where in fact we do have major
organizations from both sides of the
political spectrum joined together in a
common cause
on the right
we have in addition to the free congress
foundation eagle forum
the media research center
and the american defense institute
and john on the left
on the left we have counsel for a
livable world union of concerned
scientists peace action and center for
defense information
the question is what sort of issue could
possibly bring
bring about such a broad coalition
the issue is obviously the expansion of
nato proposal initially to admit three
new three new members and then probably
up to as many as 12.
the first concern
that the organizations that belong to
the coalition against nato expansion
share
is that we are making a move of enormous
strategic import
committing american money in the
billions of dollars
and ultimately committing the lives of
young americans
to the defense of a growing number of
countries with almost no debate
serious consideration
and certainly no engagement of the
american public the agency which
ultimately must back up any such
commitments it is not the children of
senators and congressmen who go to war
our belief the coalition's belief
is that it is
a crime against democracy
if the expansion of nato continues to be
treated
as a washington insider deal
this country does not need a ton
tonkin gulf resolution
for central and eastern europe
if there's one lesson that i believe
both the right and the left can draw
from the vietnam war
it is that important commitments
of american
prestige and again ultimately american
troops
should not be made
without participation by the american
people
the american people have no reason to
support
a commitment done
as an insider deal in the dark
the coalition against nato expansion is
determined
to do everything in its power to create
the necessary debate both in congress
and among the american people so that
this issue gets the thorough airing and
careful consideration that it merits
the arguments against nato expansion and
the coalition very explicitly is against
nato expansion
are strategic political and financial
let me touch briefly on the strategic
and then i'm going to ask john isaacs to
talk about the other two
in the course of this century our
culture the west
has fought three terrible civil wars
the first world war the second world war
and the cold war we don't usually think
of those as civil wars but if we view
the world as
a mix not merely of nations but of
cultures and increasingly of cultures in
conflict
then that is what these were
the price we paid was enormous somewhere
around 50 million people dead
incalculable losses of whole cities and
the very moral fiber of the west
ultimately
by a miracle
at the end of this terrible century
we have been offered the opportunity to
put an end to these terrible conflicts
the fall of communism in central europe
and the old soviet union
have opened the door for the
reunification of the west a west that
can and must include russia
russia is also culturally a christian
nation
russia is part of the west
and if russia is excluded from the west
as too often in the past she has been
then the consequences invariably are
once again a civil war within the west
sooner or later
this unique tremendous opportunity is
now being thrown away
by
an establishment here in washington that
is either
unwilling to think strategically or
incapable of thinking strategically
because the expansion of nato and nato
let me remind you is a military alliance
can only be directed against russia
the
nato expansion sends to russia is
unmistakable you're out and you're never
going to be in
in our view this is a tragedy and as the
old saying goes it's worse than a crime
it's a blunder
the opportunity to reintegrate the west
is not likely to occur again if we throw
it away now
and those who propose to do so
by expanding nato have an enormous
burden of explanation
that they must answer to the american
people for
so far we have heard nothing from them
on this subject true they have beaten
and cajoled the current russian
government into silence
but the entire
russian polity across this political
spectrum knows and says among itself
that this is directed against russia
because geography means it can't be
anything else it cannot be directed
against japan or india or china the
geography for that simply isn't there it
can be directed only against russia and
it is directed against russia
in our view this is a strategic blunder
as great as any that has been committed
in the west in this century as great as
the terrible errors of 1914
as great as anything that we can imagine
we are throwing away the chance of the
century literally in pursuit of little
more than some arms contracts for
the manufacturers of american fighter
planes and tanks in the usual promises
of campaign funds
and
jobs for constituents on capitol hill
and that reaches into the next area
which is political with that i'd like to
turn it over to john isaacs
thank you bill lind and thank you to the
organizations that together are joining
here to form the coalition against nato
expansion
my name is john isaacs and i'm president
of council for the livable world and i'm
here to uphold the left side of the
coalition along with as you heard before
union of concerned scientists peace
action and center for defense
information
the organizations in this room have
profound differences on many foreign
policy and national security issues
needless to say we have not found
ourselves often in the same room
planning strategy and in the same press
conferences
but we have found much to our surprise
profound agreement that the decision of
nato to accept three new countries and
perhaps many more
is a serious and great mistake for the
united states in the post-cold war era
i recently read a column by phyllis
schaffle and found much to my surprise
her arguments are my arguments
we hope that our coming together today
and joining with other groups on the
left and the right and in fact the
center
will generate a debate on this vital
national security issue both in
washington dc and around the country
bill lynn mentioned the strategic
reasons to oppose nato enlargement
i'd like to focus briefly on some of the
political concerns as well
president clinton majority leader trent
lott and senate foreign relations
committee chairman jesse helms are
determined to push this critical
decision through the united states
senate with a lemming-like march to
judgment
using as a primary argument at this
point it's a done deal you can't stop
it's too late
we're here to say it is not a done deal
this undertaking to expand nato will
involve americans in major new
commitments
and risk major new military involvements
and should be extensively debated
not only in the u s congress but around
the country
even more disturbing is the heavy
involvement in this debate
of the defense contractor lobbyists
in the working in the pro enlargement
campaign
contractors who see in the horizon at
lucrative new markets for weapon sales
in central europe
we're also concerned about the extremely
high costs of expanding nato
costs which have been variously
estimated as high as 125 billion dollars
and as low as 1.2 billion dollars
the 1.2 billion dollars being the most
recent estimate put out by nato
and in fact in recent weeks nato
officials and american leaders have been
trying to lowball the costs
of nato enlargement because of the
obvious concern of members of congress
and parliamentarians in the other nato
countries about the money that will need
to be appropriated
interestingly enough the details behind
the most recent nato estimate of 1.2
billion dollars have been classified
being kept from both the american public
other publics and parliamentarians
one thing is clear
existing nato members are little
interested in spending new money on nato
and the potential new countries of
poland the czech republic and hungary
cannot afford to spend a lot of new
money on weapons to join this elite body
also clear
is that uncle sam will be asked to pick
up a much larger part of the bill
than is now conceded
we will be working as part of this
coalition to expand the debate across
the country
in fact we challenge state department
representatives to join us in a debate
let the issues come forward let the
debate begin in the months ahead
we will be glad to debate them anywhere
across the country
we will also be cooperating with
parallel efforts such as a new group
that's about being announced shortly
called
no donato expansion speakers tour
which is expanding which is sending
distinguished experts across the country
to california oregon illinois wisconsin
connecticut new jersey florida
one final point
while we don't expect today's
announcement to produce an instant shift
in the debate
we do hope that this unusual coalition
will force
both policy makers and pundits to take a
brand new look at the issue of nato
enlargement
and the print and the profound
implications of this decision
we are confident that a close
examination of the implications of nato
enlargement will lead this country away
from this mistaken policy
let me just add a little bit from the
right
on john's challenge to the state
department to debate us the coalition
against nato expansion in cities all
over america
the state department loves to go around
the world preaching the merits of
democracy to all and sundry well we're
challenging them to practice it
and if they refuse to discuss this vital
commitment
before the american people in debates
around this country in the major cities
where ordinary people can come and
listen
then let us hear no more can't from them
about the merits of democracy because
they don't mean a word of it
we do intend to take
our campaign against nato enlargement to
the american people
we realize that the answer to the money
being promised on capitol hill through
the defense contractors is the voices of
ordinary american citizens
we are fortunate to have in our initial
coalition
two organizations which have a great
deal of strength at the grassroots
and we're going to ask them to come
forward now and say a little bit about
what they're going to do
to take the question of nato enlargement
to the american people i would like to
call first on chris artizone from eagle
forum
thank you very much my name is chris
artizone and i'm the executive director
of eagle forum and it is with pleasure
that we join in this coalition um
against the expansion of nato this is an
unusual coalition it has members of from
all across the political spectrum um and
this really reflects the ideas and
thoughts of the american people
one of the great things about our system
of government is that when the people
speak out our elected representatives do
listen and at eagle forum we are
committed to taking this message to
grassroots americans
and have them speak out about their
thoughts about it
with the expansion of nato comes many
questions that haven't been answered
and probably many of them are not even
answerable who will be
who
will we be protecting the nato countries
from why admit some of the warsaw pac
countries and not others and how much is
it going to cost us both in dollars and
u.s lives
the biggest question is why should
americans commit to defend far away
european borders that have been the
locus of ethics ethnic nationalist and
religious disputes for hundreds of years
make no mistake about it nato is a life
and death u.s promise to go to war to
protect the other members
the american people deserve the
opportunity to be heard and at eagle
forum we are going to take the message
to our grassroots and to grassroots
americans of all various uh political
stripes and get them to speak out about
what they believe
a sound foreign policy and national
defense strategy for our country is and
some people ask
eagle forum is a conservative grassroots
quote unquote pro-family organization
why would you all be interested in this
issue
we have long been interested in sound
foreign affairs and a strong national
defense policy because without strong
national defense and sound foreign
affairs you can't have strong families
and our members are very interested in
this issue and a variety of other issues
that have to do with foreign affairs and
they are very excited to get involved to
talk to their senators i mean even the
members of the house we are calling on
the house to hold hearings on the budget
issues and to hold real debates on what
this will mean to the future of our
armed forces
and the future of our country and so we
encourage both houses of congress to
hold extensive hearings and to listen to
what the american people are saying on
this vital issue thank you
and from the left gordon clark of peace
action
hi my name is gordon clark i'm the
executive director of peace action
formerly saying freeze the nation's
largest grassroots peace and disarmament
organization
uh tomorrow night when president clinton
speaks about nato expansion he's
undoubtedly going to talk about the calm
and stability that it's going to bring
over europe as you can tell the members
of the panel here completely disagree
with that i would second what bill has
said that in fact we feel that the
clinton administration is throwing away
a historic opportunity to bring peace to
the european continent
um and there are many questions in fact
which we aren't being answered questions
about how our sons and daughters are
going to be committed to conflicts in
europe
questions of why we are re-militarizing
europe at a time when we should be
demilitarizing europe questions of just
how much money american taxpayer money
is going to be spent on this again
estimates go anywhere from 1.5 billion
to 125 billion
and finally and in some ways perhaps
most importantly will this maneuver in
fact rekindle the cold war that we all
thought was behind us many of us believe
it will by pressing russia to place
greater reliance on nuclear weapons in
the face of this military expansion
against them
as other folks have mentioned here it is
indeed an unusual coalition of left and
right that comes together um and i think
it's an extraordinary time in washington
when this is not the most unusual case
of strange bedfellows going on in
washington d.c
but i do think that ultimately this is
going to be far far and away the most
important
case going on far more important than
the scandals which are now rocking the
clinton white house
my organization has certainly said times
that we are very concerned about the
partisan wrangling that goes on the
partisan bitterness that goes on in
washington dc but frankly right now we
are even more concerned when official
washington gets together and tells us
that we have nothing to worry about with
this major major policy initiative truly
the greatest one to go on since the
beginning of the cold war over 50 years
ago we think the american people should
be worried when official washington gets
together and says as john has said it's
a done deal nothing to worry about
we think the american people should be
worried when official washington gets
together and says that there's going to
be virtually no cost attached to
defending a new continent in a major
policy initiative we certainly think
that the american people should be
worried and should be clutching their
wallets and pocket books when officials
from lockheed martin the world's largest
military contractor is leading the
lobbying effort to push this new foreign
policy initiative of nato expansion
perhaps worst of all for us and i think
worst for american democracy again is
the complete lack of public and media
debate on this issue so far there used
to be a time in this country when public
debate on major foreign policy issues
was considered the norm and not the
exception and quite frankly at this
point i feel that there has been less
public and media debate on this issue
than there has been pregame analysis of
the most recent super bowl and i would
also add a look at what official
estimates of that game turned out to be
because official washington and clinton
the congress the state department
doesn't seem to have any real interest
in sponsoring true debate in the
american public on this historic
initiative it's up to us uh
organizations grassroots organizations
to do that and that is exactly what we
intend to do
this coming wednesday
will be the launching of the nate no to
nato expansion debate uh which is going
to be happening at 15 cities across
america from new york washington dc
atlanta los angeles san francisco
seattle and a number of cities in
between
people who are joining us on this tour
include dr alla yaroshinskaya whose
advisor to president yeltsin and a
former member of the russian parliament
anne clyde who's a member of parliament
from the united kingdom sir hugh beach
who's a retired four-star british
general
former senator gary hart and a number of
other noted experts from both the east
and west military diplomatic experts who
are going to be raising these questions
that we are here today about nato
expansion
i have pressed
the press conference is going to be this
coming wednesday here in washington dc
here i believe in this national press
club and we truly hope along with our
colleagues on the left and on the right
that this is going to open up a real a
true debate among the american public on
again what is we consider the most
historic and ill thought out foreign
policy initiative of this century
in addition to the
eight organizations which have founded
the coalition against nato expansion we
also have a distinguished and rapidly
growing advisory council
it includes retired senator gordon
humphrey of new hampshire
dr freddie clay
ambassador jack matlock and professor
richard pipes
i would like to call now on two members
of that advisory council to give us
their thoughts and their ideas as to
where this is going to go the first
is ted galen carpenter
from cato institute
thank you very much bill i'm ted galen
carpenter vice president for defense and
foreign policy studies at the cato
institute i want to emphasize that my
appearance here today is in my case as a
private citizen not as a representative
of the cato institute
i think it is uh
increasingly clear that advocates of
nato expansion
engage in an exercise of strategic
evasions and wishful thinking
if you listen to secretary albright and
other proponents of expansion you would
swear that an enlarged nato
is little more than an institutional
mechanism whereby everyone can gather in
the center of europe for a group hug
it is portrayed as
largely a political organization
but we need a dose of reality
nato has always to be sure had some
political dimension
but it has never been and is not now
primarily a political organization
it is a military alliance and extending
that alliance into a new area entails
very serious security obligations
and there is nothing worse than for the
united states to undertake such
obligations
without
realizing
that we might be called upon someday
to carry out those obligations again
proponents seem to assume
that the article 5
guarantee in the north atlantic treaty
that provision that provides that
an attack on any member of the alliance
is considered an attack on all
will never be challenged so we don't
have to worry about unpleasant issues
such as cost or credibility
we can expand the alliance on the cheap
as the pentagon has alleged
and that nato itself has brought in its
most recent cost estimates
now anyone who believes that a military
alliance
can carry out in a credible way
serious commitments
on less than two billion dollars
over a ten-year period is smoking
something other than tobacco
that estimate does not even pass the
straight face test
again we ought to be serious about the
consequences of expansion
there has never been in history a
military alliance that is directed
against no one that is a contradiction
in terms
military alliances always either
explicitly or at least implicitly
have an adversary
and as bill has pointed out quite
clearly
the only logical major adversary for the
alliance is russia but there are other
problems and we should remember this
article 5 does not simply state
that members must come to the aid of a
fellow member under an attack
by an expansionist great power
we would have an obligation to assist a
member that gets into a fight
involving an adversary of any sort
and if you look at the situation in
central and eastern europe that ought to
make every american uneasy
we have for example the border between
one of nato's proposed new members
poland and belarus
one of the most corrupt unstable
countries
in the international system a literal
powder keg
waiting to explode
we also have some problems between
hungary
and three of its neighbors slovakia
romania and serbia involving the
treatment of hungarian minorities in
those countries
now nato has had a great deal of
difficulty over the years
with the relationship between greece and
turkey this has been a perennial
headache for the alliance
is it really smart for u.s policymakers
to undertake commitments that involve
more situations of that sort
that's what nato expansion means
the future of the alliance if we're
lucky
will mean more bosnia-style quagmires
that's if we're lucky if you liked
nato
in bosnia you will love
nato expansion into central and eastern
europe
and the bosnia
precedent i think ought to be troubling
in another respect
we have the
wishful thinking in terms of cost
estimates
by the proponents of enlargement
let us remember
that the bosnia mission was supposed to
be a one-year mission
costing 1.5 billion dollars
that was the original estimate
we now have a mission of unlimited
duration
at a cost of eight billion dollars and
the meter is still running
senators need to ask a lot of hard
questions
to secretary albright to secretary cohen
and other administration officials
and not just accept this notion
that nato expansion is an exercise in
benign political symbolism
this is a very serious exercise
and one that could cost americans dearly
and i don't mean just in dollars thank
you
and lastly jonathan dean from union a
concerned scientist and a member of the
advisory council
good morning i am uh jonathan dean the
uh
advisor for international security
issues of the union of concerned
scientists uh i've been involved with
nato since the uh
early 50s
when i helped
get germany into nato as a member
nato in its present form
continues useful
and it provides all of the defense
that europe needs
on the other hand the enlargement
concept is a serious mistake
and the aspect of
nato expansion which i think
is most threatening for the united
states
and what should cause greatest concern
in the u.s senate is the boundless
nature of this project
there are now 12 official candidates for
nato membership
three european neutral countries are
also thinking of joining
the baltic states and romania are
scheduled for the next round
if the baltic states appear to be making
progress
ukraine will want in
that gives us 16 candidates doubling the
current membership of nato
the central asian republic of azerbaijan
has also indicated
interest in fact any membership any
member of the partnership for peace is
eligible to apply
there are 27 of these
in addition to present nato members now
there's literally
no end of this enterprise in sight the
administration refuses to place any
limits on it
consequently there is no end to the u.s
security commitments the project
involves to its costs and its risks
in the next round of enlargement if nato
commits to defend the baltic states in
romania
in order to make good on these
commitments then large numbers of nato
and u.s ground air and naval forces will
have to move into the baltic sea to the
north and also into the black sea
in the south
this will be a gigantic
military pincers movement
around the heartland of russia like the
one that hitler attempted
unless it's handled very differently
than is being handled now
this project will create the conditions
for a very dangerous long-term
confrontation with russia
the official
russian national security doctrine
adopted last december
states explicitly that russia considers
that nato expansion threatens its
national security
this is a serious statement it cannot be
fobbed off or ignored
to make an enduring enemy of the world's
largest country
with the world's largest nuclear arsenal
and with endless capacity to cause
difficulties for the united states
is an enormous cost
and this is especially the case
for a project whose immediate object
of securing democracy in eastern europe
can be achieved by other means without
any additional cost or risk
thanks
that concludes the formal part of this
news conference we have copies of the
statement the founding statement of the
coalition against nato expansion on the
table outside the door a number of the
member organizations have also brought
copies of their own papers on nato
expansion and i would urge you to uh to
feel free to take copies of those as
well
we are now open for questions
yes um mr lynn post
i guess i'm curious i would assume you
all have
done your analysis far and wide what
happens in the event that
the senate
votes down
uh nato expansion what happens in terms
of u.s relations with
poland hungary the czech republic most
of which have indicated that obviously
that they're quite interested and they
don't mention them with the
well those countries
those countries need us far more than we
need them
and
i do not foresee any significant change
in our relations with any of those
countries
our need their need for commercial ties
with us for diplomatic ties with us will
remain very strong
and in turn to be quite blunt about it
there's not much they have to offer us
so i think it's very clearly a one-way
street here and i think that one-way
street leads to them continuing
to want to be on our good side i think
there's a further
answer to that question but if you're
doing it to mike's i appreciate it all
right sure
uh
nato will continue under those
circumstances the partnership for peace
will continue under those circumstances
and the
uh
enlargement current enlargement of the
european union which will get started in
march and of which all of the
candidates for nato membership the
official candidates except albania and
macedonia are on the list that that too
will continue
and i would imagine that if this
situation does come coming to come to
pass
that there will be increased interest
in the other unnamed security
organization in europe the organization
for security and cooperation
which
if the major members like the united
states gave it more
support and more money
would
indeed
gain in seriousness and public attention
let me just add the ambassador makes a
very important point there are many
vehicles for bringing the countries in
central and eastern europe into closer
ties with the west
the most important and the most
appropriate fairly very clearly is the
european union
not a military alliance which again the
point's been made by a number of the
speakers must by its nature be directed
against someone that is of course not
true of something like the european
community
other questions yes
do you have any uh support from members
of senators a couple senators have
spoken out against nato expansion in the
past but seem to have gone loot on the
issue do you have any uh base of support
within the senate to to start your
campaign john i'm not sure you've been
kind of watching this more closely than
we have i'm not sure that there's anyone
who has gone public yet
but i'll let you let you address that
the senate of course has not been in
session for the last three months and so
they have been senators have been pretty
quiet on this issue in most issues
we are hopeful that with a congress
returning tomorrow that several senators
who have been quiet to this point will
raise their voices and question and say
that they formally oppose nato
enlargement
there are a number of senators who
indicated during hearings and other
discussions that they are seriously
concerned about nato enlargement this is
last fall but they were not prepared to
oppose outright nato enlargement we hope
that the they will get this courage and
this uh
they will raise the level of concern to
public opposition in the next couple
weeks
i would also add that as you've heard
this morning these senators are going to
be from the grassroots on this issue i
think that it is
one of the washington laws is the law of
conservation of enemies
if senators don't think there's going to
be opposition to something
they're not going to come out and risk
making enemies in a hopeless cause our
message to the senate the message of
this news conference the message of the
founding of this organization
is precisely that there is going to be
opposition there is going to be very
serious opposition there's going to be
thoughtful opposition there is going to
be widespread opposition among the
american public and i think that will
give the significant number of senators
who themselves are uncomfortable about
this and have been saying privately that
they are uncomfortable about this
the platform they need and the implicit
impetus they need to go public
other questions
other than bruce jackson's membership in
a committee that's thrown a few dinner
parties do you have any evidence of uh
defense contractors uh bankrolling or
pushing this thing oh absolutely i i
worked as staff on capitol hill for 13
years myself i have many friends still
up there and and they tell me they're
they're they're like
like flies at a july picnic
any further questions
very well again i uh i suggest you take
a look at the the founding statement of
of the coalition against nato expansion
and at the papers the organizations who
are members have produced they're on the
table outside thank you for coming
for the news as your response to his
vision of river crash
and i'm still going through my notes
um
this morning on washington journal on
the return of kong